CU what is
that
no no God I didn't see it until after
you saw
it citizens of the reject Nation I don't
know the sax is it just came out I'm
Tera and this is Aaron hello I'm Ain and
we're watching The Strangers oh gr baby
yeah I've never seen it I've never seen
it either is it spooky we don't know
okay it might be cuz look at my shirt
we're in the season so you guys got to
remember leave a like you got to type in
there leave a comment be cool be nice
and then also ring the
bell ring the bell also if you haven't
joined patreon we call you super sexy
over there like who doesn't want to be
called super sexy do you want to be
called super sexy I I wish nothing more
right exactly so if you get on there you
can watch the full watch long you can
sink up with your own copy with me and
this guy and we're going to watch this
movie together all of us and also Greg
and John offer exclusive highlights and
watch alongs over there on patreon which
is also super super sexy so I think
that's the whole Jam do we feel like
we're good to watch I feel like I'm good
to watch I think you look like you're
good to watch I feel like I'm good so
we're just going to go watch
it what you are about to see is inspired
by true events okay all righty true true
there are an estimated 1.4 4 million
violent crimes in America each year
that's a lot that's believable yeah
February 11th 2005 Christen McCay and
James Hoy left a friend's wedding
reception the brutal events that took
place there are still not entirely known
God oh my God this I'm immediately
tense oh this is real this makes it
scarier oh my God all right I'm ready
911 what's your emergency are you there
there there are people here okay calm
down whoa what's your address I don't
know are you in danger yes yes that's a
cool shot yeah it's a heart dope Jordan
who are you with we we went in the house
we found
people we you found who Jordan there's
blood on the walls help us oh my God
Jordan what happened there there's blood
everywhere
okay all right really sets the tone
inform good setup like a good like kind
of cold
open oh my God I just am realizing
that's Liv Taylor is that yeah Liv
Taylor and I the other guy I recognized
him that's okay yeah live Tyler live
yeah the you know the singer's daughter
stepen Tyler yeah yeah his daughter yeah
I'm saying it right right
yeah I think
so yeah oh it is her hey I know her from
Incredible
Hulk it's like they had a rough
night when did you do all this I was
trying to salvage the
marriage yeah I don't know about the top
I didn't know if the Ros was going first
or
after yeah I don't know either wow this
is a really interesting feeling to Come
Away with leaving a wedding
yeah you think something happened or
just a reminder of how their marriage is
on the Rocks I feel like something
happened feel like his knuckles look
bruised in the car oh likey Mike it's me
um we're at the house now I know you're
drunk I thought you want to see you but
things see like is that yeah something
definitely happened I'm going to need
you to come out here and get me call me
when you get this what did you do my guy
yeah like what happened who did you
punch the
Groome oh find out thank goodness I just
want to tell you
something I remember the first time I
ever saw you
[Music]
getting the feeling she said
no okay yeah it's really nice everything
you did it's
beautiful I can't keep it I can't take
it back I would just pawn it what's she
going to do with it pawn it
right I'm Rick Harrison and this is my
pawn shop I'm so sorry it wasn't the way
you thought it would be I'm just not
ready
yet James please please talk to me it's
got to sting I hope he didn't make like
a big show of it that would be worse
window I like how someone just
communicated without actually saying
anything yeah and also in the the music
choices
great you are my
girl are we going to make sad love
yeah no why is it so loud oh God like
the water
no oh great they were just about to fix
things or end things I don't know
there's no
people I'm clinched oh God
but oh god what the what the mysterious
face in darkness
hello so
creepy what the is what I'm scared you
can't even see your face dude that's so
terrifying oh my God Tam here no you got
the wrong house
I cannot see her face and it's driving
me wild these movies some Shadows is
crazy she seemed okay I mean think she
would have said if she
wasn't
okay I'm out a cigarette I'll go give
you some more she killed the vibe I'll
just go to sleep I'm tired anyway no you
won't I'll try it's all right I want to
drive for a while anyway let me light
you a fire I'm like does she already not
sleep or is it just cuz tonight but
still I'm like it's like 5:00 a.m. by
now okay I'll be back you going to be
okay here yeah I'll be
fine this whole vibe is very
[Music]
ominous the choice to have this all like
a handheld is raise is like for me the
anxiety uh I mean i' like handheld shots
but it like it makes me feel right there
yeah I know it's very very intimate
[Music]
yes oh shoot can she not get it off
you're married now you guys are engaged
now you can't take it
off and you can
theing
oh God why did that scare me so bad I
don't know it got me too
dude I'm in defensive position so I
didn't Shake as bad but yeah
that oh God here we
go yeah that's a hell no for
me okay this is so tense oh my
God hello Pizza Hut is there Tam home
Tamara it's the same girl you already
came by here yeah
girl are you sure oh my God her
so
[Music]
no no what okay no she locked it she
locked it she locked it she locked it
good girl oh God okay good girl we're
not doing this dumb horror movie stuff
not tonight no no she locked it right
locked that [__] down lock lock it down
girl close out the blinds Tamera is not
here close all the blinds and watch your
behind don't do
it go to the window don't go to the
window if you go to the window you got
to shut off the lights first so they
can't see you you're going to see
something you don't want to see I am so
tense right
now God it's like my stomach is just
like ready
out of all the movies we've watch this
is the most
tense see saw was gross this is just
terrorizing Texas chainsa was disturbing
this is tense and I'm actually
scared great that the the the flute
wasn't open oh Lord I hate this this
sound design is making me panic which I
know that that is the goal all of the
sounds and the fire
no don't like it I don't like it at all
please don't fall
off God Jesus no no no no no no help no
girl you better grab a knife come on now
don't do it grab a knife do not open
that door like a like a gun like a taser
or something a knife anything I'd grab
the lamp and a knife grab a grab a
something double up no what is she doing
she doing good she has her flip phone
okay okay all right yep call the 911s
just call them now she's going to call
him I guarantee
it
dead oh
god dude the sound design is
crazy and the
music lowkey unnerving High key
unnerving yeah I key except it's at a
low volume right now James right where
are
you that girl came back yeah girl you
got to not be calling James knocking on
the
door house I'm just afraid she's I heard
her voice be right there and I can't
handle
it why are you getting undressed this is
anxiety I got to move got to get the
anxiousness out my body
okay just want you to come home okay
thank God yes you're putting on this is
all smart I agree with everything she's
doing will you just stay on the phone
with
me is it Power claims is it the
power
no oh I hate this so
much dude nothing's even happened yet
I'm scared what the I'm like Bravo to
this movie for making me feel terrified
In This Moment before anything even
happens dude oh my
God
what the is what
is no oh God I didn't see it until after
you saw it Oh
God oh my
God oh my God I despise this I despise
no why is it no
no this is so
creepy no no no
no what the I might die before this
movie's over just sheer fear fall over
from Pure Heart Attack are you going to
see it or what is that it's
gonee no
nope I am not in the mood right now I
don't even want to bro I even you see I
used to think that I didn't like horror
movies and I've been watching horror
movies and I'm I'm like yeah you're not
that bad this this is why this
is yes thank God finally yes a weapon
gra grab a grab a something please break
a glass grab the candle get a knife have
them all lined up honey it's the [__] in
the shadows that always gets me dude
this be hereditary God Tam was that
Tamara in the court that's or that girl
was like are you sure and that scary ass
Tamara were you in the house the whole
time how did you I feel like Tam's down
there because where where could where
could this scary mask have gone
where no no no
no they're just people they're just
people
God this is making me have like a this
I'm I'm losing it I have like a panic
I'm losing
it
God all
right
they're behind you dude there's
someone's ass how did it end up there
how is it on the chair
now some one's playing mind games with
you what's a scratchy scratchy
noise nope oh God I want to uh no please
don't no no
no I don't pray this is when I would
start praying I would start I would
start right
now leave now leave please leave from
this place at
once don't
even don't even oh my God why no what
why is it so
loud it's like that on purpose the sound
design you imagine if you have those
tissues in your so point I have some
tissues and it's
still yep okay all right okay we're in
it now we're in it
now no what why is the door on what they
opened
it how hell
no and the skipping to this [__] is
haunted the record
off cut it off no why
just
no lock it LO don't don't do that don't
do that I'm
stressing girl you need to call
911 oh my
God at this point I would just I would
have all the candles in there light the
place on fire no we're never going to
get out of it no hate it
get out of the house right
now okay okay
yep what
awful in the the record dude like
someone take the needle off or something
bro this is a for the love of
[Music]
God I take it back I take it
back I regret it
immediately
go grab the lamp too come on oh oh no
he's here but I'm not I'm I don't feel
safe
what
oh here now listen to her dude I saw a
man at the back door he's wearing a mask
his King ass
Mas I don't know did you get the
cigarettes yeah exactly cuz she's going
to need them right about now she's going
to need them she's stressed out come
here no don't tell her to come here you
go look around the house go clear it if
you're so sure you going on a route
you're asking dumbass questions and
where are the cigarettes where the damn
cigarettes yeah we're going to need them
you going to even check the whole house
bro what are we doing okay good you got
to want to burn them you want to burn
them with the cigarettes that's your
only play at this
point just like
just right in the
[Music]
eye nice stogy in the
eye bur in the fall dude oh this is this
is wacka do wild SL demented this shit's
over pure teror I don't like it no
thanks where are they at now they're in
the garage oh God I don't know I don't
want to know I don't want to know
anything anymore I I just want to stop
existing what is she doing why is she
what she what is she doing I'll marry
you if you just get me the hell out of
here she's watching
us she looks like a ghost this when we
you leave want going to go talk to her
they don't want to talk they want
something people just don't stand out
there staring at us like that they want
something yeah your lives going my phone
in the car I'm going to go get it are
you God one of them came in here and
took my phone yeah is it burning nobody
came in here in the fireplace and she's
gone I would just go out and stab the
air until I stab somebody to get my
phone keep on swinging the fact that
you're walking casually sir I do not
agree with this Choice you're acting
like a dumb character you better be
waving that knife around right now proof
proof
sir they slash the
tires I feel like they slashed the tires
and they broke the
windshield they took out that they took
out the
windows Randy Savage on their asses oh
my
God but you can't drive like that what's
he doing he turnning it off or you
trying to go you're driveing the glass
cut your tires what are we why are we
what are we
doing what was the point of that you got
me stressed rubing my forehead come on
man I would drive the car right up to
the front door so
that
no
my nope I'm sorry for the language guys
oh wow wow wow wow wow wow
wow this is not okay this is not okay no
okay tell her what what do you want it's
okay get out what do you want yeah thank
you right this mother out of here thank
you that's not going to work but like
it's the thought there's another person
no Kristen go back inside what's
happening
Christen what is this running around
you're running around you're screwed
he's fast he's fast he touch he's he was
touching your ear there she goes all
right that's what face move the car to
the front door if you're not going to
leave right now I mean you already got
inside what's that going to do at this
point an escape plan just walk away just
just walk home hit don't hitch hike but
just walk home I would just drive the
car right now just get out of there he's
in there he's like tickling in his neck
and [__] no I think he got out of
there and it's so dark it's so dark like
this movie really knows how to play with
shadows and lighting to make make you
feel just isolated is all get
up we know someone has a shotgun we saw
that at the beginning of the yeah on the
counter no since we've been here I just
I haven't heard a dog bark or a car pass
nothing would probably disinfect at
first but that's okay yeah listen to
Listen to terara take take one of those
candles and just throw it at her that's
what I'm saying you took the
battery oh yeah it's just m games left
and right in here we got to get out of
here you what who what why the music uh
y'all should be slicing the air I mean
at least they're being trying to be
smart now at yeah I just you want to
check the back seat first before you
just drive or the trunk or the
trunk oh no no no no okay he's going
slow is that the Buddy is that your
friend it's going to oh it's going to
it's going to W
you the lights
off no she's going to get
you
why oh my
gosh get out run oh my gosh oh my gosh
oh my gosh what what
what you're done it's it's over you're
done now yeah you need to start
barricading the house every window every
door every no and Granny it's war time
baby hey we got a gun all right I don't
know if that's going to save us they'
already gotten into the house we need to
start
barricading I mean it's giving me hope
but like I think it's false there better
be bullets I hope you guys win I don't
know how you're going to win but I hope
you do why does
okay see see
see see hello hello inside I've never
yelled so much in a movie in my life I'm
not saying hi back hello click Hello
Goodbye that's where I
stand you guys you guys you guys you
need to barricade yourself in a room in
a closet I don't know looking
fors God got I got him I got
him oh you got bullets okay thank
goodness okay we're doing load that puy
up somebody should be standing there
with a knife though too what why why are
you guys both looking there somebody
somebody KN it somebody with the lamp
what do you mean a a knife a lamp a he
said he used to hunt with your dad he's
a liar I never did was just was
something I said why would you say that
come on bro you've seen movies you know
how to load it you're done my guy going
to run why are we going
outside shoot oh my God you need to
learn to load the gun I would set the
house on fire I would set it on
fire barricade good
job good
shot uh now go make them all off
cocktail come on y'all come on rip off
those clothes get it on fire put it in a
bottle listen to Tera we're not going to
die here I'm going to wait for the cops
to come or whatever I'm not going to
die oh my God what we what are we what
are we doing sound what are we doing my
guy
what no hell no hell no oh bro this is a
mind got the friend this movie is so
dark I the friend oh is it the friend to
pick him up yeah yes yo oh at Le Always
Sunny oh [__] it is it's Mike listen man
I'm outside I I got here early I just
decided to come out and you know Glen
pow that's his name soon as I possibly
could cuz you know how I like to wait on
you hand
foot okay so you're dead first you're
the
example and this is how you watch a man
die
[Music]
no thank
you oh this is awful oh my
[Music]
gosh just having a good old terrorizing
ho
down and you're
[Music]
dead oh jeez that is
spooky I'm going to ask you a question
what what his friend shut up his
friend y
well oh that's the blood stain on the
wall that's how it happened he saw a
friend of the damn face what you what do
you mean he didn't have a
mask you your friend in the effing head
now your friend is
dead uh yes that's what I said cuz now
that sucks you're kind of going away for
me solder
probably what
is M
okay don't do that you're show give him
away your location don't do that oh
that's awful that's so bad dude this is
terrible and to think a rejection
proposal was the worst thing he thought
was going to happen that night I mean of
all night of a crazy surprise
right after this she better be like
we'll get married and just we'll live in
peace I asked the girl that Lov to marry
me and she said no and that wasn't even
the craziest part of my night
dude I'm going to go inside you be
outside like five times bro you went
outside like three times come on what
else to do with what
phone to go out
what oh that's quick that's quick work
that's quick work that's Twitter right
there that's that's quick that's quick
with the
[Music]
response everything and he takes the gun
what what do she do what okay get get
one of the the the Antiques and you need
to close that what is going on either
you go with him or you need to start
putting together weapons this is wasted
time this is dumb horror movie [__] it's
making me upset why would you split up
ever why would you split up go get a
weapon
[Music]
girl are you going to the barn you going
to the barn now sweet little stroll to
the
barn moloto tail find
alcohol come on what is this what is
this oh is that a killer is that a
stranger are they stranger over there is
that a m i can't tell it's so dark I
think it's like it's super dark I can't
tell who the hell it is I think it is a
master is a stranger you're too far for
the shotgun
bro oh you're done you got
got S I was going to scare you just now
but I don't think I have it in me I
changed my mind I wasn't going to heart
attack already dude I already have one I
don't even have it in me do it nope not
for this one no no no no what is he
going to do is he going to talk towards
his kill right away just breathing like
a
weirdo we've been trying to contact you
about your extended warranty on your
Hyundai
[Laughter]
alantra in in the in the no no
no what's going to
happen I don't even know what you broke
but it sounded bad I heard a
crunch whoa that's a disorienting camera
move right
there oh the sound design it's pretty
amazing pretty
incredibly God oh my God why how why
and she's gone oh they're just toying
with you you're you're you're just your
little play things they love mind games
no playing with the Mind
Games grab that
wrench grab a tool please for the love
of God own axe you have a whole
repertoire of weapons you can use in
there you better start start at it girl
just pick one pick pick anything get a
chainsaw why don't
you yeah I don't even want to I don't
even want to know I don't and it's going
to happen soon hey
where what what what they just laugh
what they just
leave oh a radio hey that radio girl get
it going just give us a little glimmer
of
hope the shaky Cam man my God they're
behind you you lost the bandage on your
hand there oh God what what
where what's the
footsteps hello can you hear
me help
me
[Music]
okay yeah stay low AR crawl they just
want to torture them they want to
torture
you oh it's it's a potato sack okay
potato sack isn't doesn't Hees see
her why are you guys playing with them
dude if you want to kill them just kill
them already exactly here is this girl
there's a third one third girl oh no how
many are
there well two of them see there's a
fire what no the
car I mean they know where she is so
like what are they
doing I don't know moloto cocktail oh
are we going to find was there two guns
and she took one of that no there was
only one I think there was just like the
wasn't a fleet gun what oh where I can't
see how are they going to see what you
guys got night
vision is it morning yet I hear so hell
no hell no
why bro come on
oh okay all right
well he doesn't see you you got to get
the upper hand you got to do something
he doesn't know where you are yeah but
those girls do the girls know they they
got the intuition they got the intuition
on a murder
Mission breathing is so unsettling and
where's your husband at I mean where's
your
boyfriend oh my God oh my God I saw that
coming I saw that I knew that was going
to happen I felt it I felt it in my
bones felt in my giblets
what the
wedding he's going to kill you who your
man's he's
dead are we about to have a knife off
right now you just get a screwdriver are
you for
reals who's that who
man
me potato sack
[Applause]
[Music]
okay all right
damn I try to scratch the floor
man what is that How It Ends what what
happens what am I seeing I was looking
at Darkness right
now oh they tied them up
oh my
God it's morning oh oh it's daytime now
the survive the
night oh hell
no why dude
why why are you doing this to us cuz you
were home what cuz you were home yo
that's sick that's just evil that's
that's
nefarious
oh they're taking their masks off okay
she took her mask off are we going to
show her face you don't have to
do you can stop now you he already knows
guy already
knows just in the stomach
man oh my God oh my God God in the heart
this is so effed
[Music]
up oh
God oh my God oh my God why why God
why oh some some little Mormon bo boys
are going to find him Yep they're the
ones that called wasn't it a woman on
the phone who called 911
no that was the operator I think it was
these K it's they sto their truck oh
[Music]
man you see their kind of faces are you
a sinner
sometimes sometimes this woman said
sometimes
oh these kids are our
only Witnesses why did they next time
wait what is she you say something about
next time next
time don't go in the house you dummies
why would any kids morbid curiosity yeah
that wouldn't be
me looks like somebody sinned in here
where is
she where' she go oh where did they put
her oh they just move their bodies
about
what she's not dead
what why does it say that we still don't
fully know if this is true if that girl
is still
alive she can identify that I'm losing
it oh my
go
uh wow uh that
was
insane yeah that was uh that was that
was rough that was that was a
lot um I it was so tense so tense
um wow dude that was that was crazy I've
never I've never even seen a frame of
this movie I didn't even know me neither
I v I vaguely knew it was like a home
invasion type of thing but I didn't know
was this I didn't know anything about it
and from beginning to end I was on the
edge of my seat I did get mad that she
didn't grab a weapon there was a lot of
weapons around and she didn't grab one
and that always makes me mad they were
doing dumb horror movie stuff yeah yeah
which I get it for the sake of movie but
then it's not it's not a movie so maybe
they had to do it because it's a true
story based on true offense I'm I'm
going to be UPS ESS I need to find this
and know if that girl is still alive
right I want I need to know the details
of the story now they actually said
because you were home bro that mine was
so chilling that just that was so sick
because you were home because you
answered the door because we could
that's just awful insane I mean the
decision on cinematography in regards to
having it handheld just raised the
stakes for it for me just that POV it
feels like once we reveal the scary
people anytime that camera is behind any
of them or near them we just feel like
it's the POV of like the scary person um
it's just I great job on cinematography
sound design and I think there might
have been a score in the beginning
because I was saying there was a
low-key music under
record right where it seemed a little
bit in the beginning but they yeah wow
what a mind game
I normally I feel like we could guess
maybe what's coming next mhm I had no
idea yeah no I was I was on my toes on
my my tippy toes from start to finish I
had no idea what was going to happen
when it was going to happen uh yeah just
to kind of build off of what you said I
thought there their use of sound design
was incredible from the crunching to the
footsteps and their use of their use of
uh lighting or or lack thereof their use
of Shadows was incredible because this
air of of mystery uh just like permeates
throughout the entire film and also
shout out to Liv Tyler she was
incredible she was brilliant she was
like just really in there you I felt
like she was actually going through this
and yeah it really made you connect and
empathize with these characters I
thought the the choice of them being a
couple on the Rocks was very interesting
and it's like it's bittersweet in a way
cuz like you you find these two people
that care about each other that love
each other but for some reason or
another that we don't find out within
the film that there was like a riff or
like she said no there seems like the
end of their relationship and by the end
of this traumatizing experience they are
Choose Love in a way because she's
wearing the ring and they're like they
love each other before they die and it's
just it's really sad man it's just so
tragic and it's like I was you you saw I
was I was like terrified from like start
to finish just like her and
I I I heard there's more of these
there's like two or three more of these
these stranger movies really okay so now
we're thinking that them in the
beginning being like this is based on a
true story I'm I'm just so curious how
much of it is is a based on that and how
much of it is written um whatever
choices were made they were all good
ones but if this is all
true that's rough uh Liv Tyler and Scott
Speedman great chemistry great casting
um It's Always Sunny guy he came in just
for just for a little for a little taste
little Cameo sorry had to die so quick
we love you too um but yeah live is what
to me especially towards the end I mean
live Tyler brought it like she is just
so good it got me thinking like where
has she been MH um cuz she's she's great
I I don't know I feel TI
tired I feel tired cuz I was a little
bit on edge the whole time um yeah
uh I feel bad for those kids too the
kids at the end if I believe that they
were the ones on the call not with 911
just losing it and I'm like oh yeah
you're going to be damaged for a long
time oh yeah live Tyler too since she
find out she lives at the end of this
movie yeah yeah just all all of them
involved are just traumatized from this
entire experience uh something yeah
something else I want to say I know we
kind of said there's a little bit of a
score I like the way this movie weapon
IED uh silence the way it used the the
lack of sound to really uh heighten the
tension of the film and I kind of said
it during the reaction I don't watch a
lot of horror movies or I didn't for a
large majority of my life so I'm not
super uh engrossed within the the horror
culture whether it be uh Freddy Jason
and all the other uh Pinhead or I don't
know all of the other horror movies
there are and for a long time I didn't
really watch horror movies because
because I thought it would get scared
but over time as I grow to watch these
movies I find it more uh entertaining
than like legitimately terrifying and
this this is what Young me was terrified
of watching because yeah I was on my
toes I was anxious I was I was dancing I
was I was trying to relieve fear y'all
there was one point I think we both
started busting up laughing because it
was like the only emotion that I just
couldn't I it was either scream or there
silence and I just started laughing I
don't know I guess our bodies need to do
something to release the tension that
the movie created yeah so it was very
successful in what it was trying to do
so I mean obviously not a fun experience
to say the least but it was a very very
good movie and it was only an hour and a
half I think hour and 25 minutes so they
really use their their screen time and
their and their screen time and their um
their runtime effectively and
efficiently and they really took their
time at the top too I I meant to say
that while we were watching it as they
took their time with the shots
especially with Liv in the house of just
staying on her she's just there standing
in the house and when you're like and
then you kind of like oh we're still
waiting and we're waiting and that first
reveal oh my God oh my goodness so
good scary I mean we both lost it I mean
it just the the way that they utilized
again the Shadows bringing up uh the
people and then just those masks are
very very scary it's just they did a
really good job on everything I'm tired
I don't have like all my thoughts
together because that was that was a
roller coaster of emotions but I'm for
me the rating would be a nine out of 10
I think it's it's a Bravo freaking film
I mean if you want to be like who wants
to
watch a terrifying movie for Halloween
this to me is truly terrifying meaning
like you guys have to sit there and
watch it it's very scary I want to show
this movie to my mom watch her react to
it oh my
God be like you need to drink some wine
first otherwise you might have a heart
attack right H yeah I don't know do you
have any last thoughts except that I do
I do love this movie I would recommend
it to friends but I would never I don't
maybe it'd be fun to like watch it again
cuz now I know what the what's going on
it wouldn't be as scary right like I
could I could watch it again with
friends probably now that I know what
the juice is but I would watch it to
watch them react to it I agree with that
yep okay that's where we're at to see
how other
people yeah also quickly I want I like
the fact that they didn't show their
faces I think it just adds to the
mystery like this this ominous nature of
who these people were like it's kind of
because you never see their faces it
makes them something other than human in
spite the fact that they are humans that
are just like sick and demented who did
this because they were home apparently
just because they could which is wild uh
yeah I I also find it very odd that they
took off the mass like they showed
themselves while killing them which is a
way it made it even sicker like feeding
them like you have to look at me while I
kill you right
which is just extra yeah show their
faces like oh you're going to die so
we're the last faces you see the people
that have been tormenting you all that
where the last faces you're going to see
before you die which is awful uh so yeah
I would give this
movie I'm tossed up between a 8.5 and a
nine cuz of cuz dumb horror characters
making dumb choices I know it madees me
yeah and you guys heard me yell about it
a lot I I'm going to I'm going to you
know I'm going to try my go I'm going to
go 8.5 great film yeah great film got
take off those points for for from dumb
choices but everything else was
incredible and that's why I'm like oh is
it dumb choices or did that actually
happen meaning are they writing that or
is this is this just like Oh that girl
just didn't think to pick up a we okay I
think him leaving her for like multiple
times in spite of the fact that they
know people I feel as a human it's dumb
as a human and I feel like as a partner
I wouldn't just leave my my girl just by
herself when we know this is going down
so I feel like that was dumb writing
everything else like obviously When
You're In the Heat of the Moment you
don't think clearly but I feel like if
I'm the protector of my partner I'm
going to make sure that they're safe and
with me through all experiences cuz one
we just know horror movies you don't
split up that's just like horror movie
101 right so yeah I would say that aside
this was a fantastic film and I am
landing on an 8.5 8.5 I'll I'll stick to
nine even though I'm again sad she never
chose a weapon she had a lot of tools
and that shed when she was asking for
help so many options that stuff makes me
upset anyway that's all we got you guys
leave a like leave a comment tell us how
you liked it uh and tell us how great we
are you know just the usual stuff you
guys cuz you know we love so much and I
guess that's it we'll see you on the
next one yeah bye
[Music]
adios